that's so serious
it was interesting coming to terms with
like letting go of that light dream that
I've had for like X amount of years
right it is a platform to organize hey
everyone how's it going it's my you go
today I am joined by Amy codes she is a
system software engineer and she also
has her own YouTube channel talking
about tech thing so welcome Amy thank
you I'm so excited to be here thank you
for being here so today I thought we
would talk about kind of like what your
background has been how you got into
tech a lot of y'all are really
interested in that sort of stuff and so
now that we have someone who does some
something pretty different from what I
do yeah I thought we could do that and
also you could check out her channel
where she talks more about this stuff
later as well
cool awesome so my first question I have
for you Amy is how did you get into
software engineering that is a really
good question so actually it was a it's
a very serendipitous story so in college
freshman year I studied cellar biology
neuroscience so I was premed up until
that point I was like I'm gonna be a
doctor I'm going to be a surgeon and
freshman year I realized like yeah this
is not really gonna work out I don't
know if you remember the online platform
omegle where it's like you get matched
with like a random person so I used to
have like five our conversations on the
messenger text thingy with these like
random strangers and one of them might
happen to be talking to him I happen to
be also picking classes at the time and
then he goes oh you should try a
computer science so it's like okay why
not
and so that is like the crazy story of
like how I got into computer science
software engineering yeah and the rest
is history day
so sir connected with that person yeah
um and I get like kept in touch with him
for maybe like a year and a half or so
you helped me get my first internship
it's only how we all like like randomly
find the things that were meant to do
for the rest of our lives
yeah I mean it's like I love my job I
love what I do and I have like a also
serendipitous thing in terms of like how
I got into the niche that I got into
which I can talk about later maybe yeah
a lot of my life is just really
serendipitous I guess yeah I'm just open
to it I don't know no how do you ever
like coded before you declare your major
in like high school um no I mean in high
school I was part of this like summer
program where they like briefly talked
about like circuits and code and stuff
but like nothing stuck I wasn't super
interested in it I don't think it was
like a super like strong introduction
into computer science that stuff's I
don't know that I counted as much
because I didn't find my interest in
computer science at that program but I
mean the program was great and like the
people there were great but yeah prior
to that nope didn't code I'm hearing
like in high school you were in like oh
I'm gonna say computer science can no no
no not at all like I was also like a
certified EMT in high school so like
yeah full like full speed away in terms
of like I wanna be a doctor you know so
it was interesting coming to terms with
like letting go of that like dream that
I've had for like X amount of years
right but I think it's also due tonight
like being naive and young and like not
knowing what else is out there yeah that
way you don't know you don't know what
you don't know yeah that's not a crazy
story yeah so yeah I wanted to ask you
like how did you get into the niche that
you did get into for software
engineering yeah sure so in my
internships and stuff like that I had
been doing back-end web development I
had two internships at behan so I did
back-end web developer for that I knew
like after like for one when I was
searching for full-time employment I
didn't want to do back-end web
development it wasn't that I was an
expert by any means but it was to me it
felt like I was turning a lot out a lot
of like
crops like credit API things so I felt
like I had done a lotta and I wanted to
check something new and so my friend she
just goes yeah follow this girl her name
is Jessie Frizzell on Twitter and I was
like okay and then she started talking
about go the programming language about
containers about container restriction
and so I was like oh this seems really
interesting so about three months prior
to like interviewing full time I learned
to go and then I started interviewing
for all these like infrastructure
companies oh cool so that's sort of like
how is also serendipitous like if my
friend hadn't told me the follow this
person I've never never known yeah so
you work at hep geo right now in Seattle
can you tell us a little bit about what
you do there yeah so I am a system
software engineer and what that means is
is that I work in distribute systems so
like a lot of systems interacting with
each other and so day to day I work with
a programming language go I also work
with a lot of containers kubernetes and
do development on that so the main goal
of hep teo is ultimately to make human
aid easy to use and then the other main
thing is we want to work really tightly
with upstream communities and not make
for instance our own like courageous
show that's like not the aim at all and
so that's that's what I work on and like
I love the founders I love my co-workers
yeah it's really cool what can I ask you
a question no stupid question go ahead
what what is kubernetes sure
so let me I've actually done talks about
this before so let me start from the
beginning are you familiar with a
container is okay are you familiar with
a virtual machine is Soyuz ok cool so
for those of you don't know virtual
machines are a way for you to virtualize
another operating system within your
machine so let's say you have like
Windows and you want to run like a Mac
operating system it's not a container
sorry but it's like the best way it's
the best analogy that I think most
people have find tangible so for
containers what it is is it
virtualizes
another operating system so you can
containerize things and make it run in
the specific operating system and so the
main thing for containers is that it's a
way to easily reproduce your your
infrastructure so let's say like you're
working locally right and you have you
know Mac OS you have Python 3.5 I don't
know what version is the latest I don't
I don't work with my thumb but you have
Python 3.5 and then you have like other
things that you've installed so what you
want to do is like you don't want to
have a situation in which it's like oh
well it works on my machine right so
let's say someone else has Python 3.7 or
something like that so you want to make
it consistent in production so what you
do is is you containerize your leg let's
say web application so you put that into
a binary and then you make sure that
there's a lot of like setup scripts and
things like that then make sure that you
have the correct operating system the
same versioning things like that and you
can terrorize that on top of that
there's a lot of things and so the way I
like to describe containers is that it's
a baby computer inside a larger computer
with a larger computers or server so the
other thing we need to do is have
another organizational structure on top
of our baby computers so there's things
like networking there is like how each
container will kill Ike talk to each
other it's things like scheduling so if
a container of die is like what happens
then so that's like a lot of like
organizational things on top of that
that kubernetes as a platform provides
so I don't know if that was a good
explanation but yeah so the way I like
to describe kubernetes is that it is a
platform to organize baby computers
oh yeah so like yeah I think you're like
people make it more complicated than it
is
um and the reality is it's like it's
pretty approachable
i I'll like give you a link to maybe one
of my talks that I you've done that cute
con and I think it's a pretty good
pretty good intro and I'll like try to
like turn that talk into a video as well
eventually yeah would be awesome yeah
yeah in the description box below for
her talk yeah it's a it's a good fun
space I love them to shucks yourself I
love working with different systems yeah
so that's really awesome Amy I am really
curious like kind of what are your
current goals and like what are the
things that you are trying to improve
and accomplish within your career yeah
so currently my main focus is just like
clocking in time as an engineer and
really understanding the domain that I
work in like the knee should I work in
and just I would love to be I don't know
if like well known as the good word but
like respected for my knowledge in
distribute systems and crannies and
things like that and that's like my
current goal and then also my company
actually they have a really amazing
remote culture so eventually it would be
really cool to like sort of like live a
semi like digital nomad so don't fly
because I love traveling
obviously I need money to travel I also
happen to like my job so I'm really
lucky in that sense yeah um yeah that's
like I just wanted to be caught I want
to ramp up as quickly as possible I
would love to become like a team tech
lead at some point you know like lead
direction of product that we develop or
maybe like an important feature and just
keep on growing and in terms of like
outside like direct or kind of stuff
other things I want to do is so I
already do some tech conference speaking
I would love to ramp up more to do more
like deep dives in terms of my
conference speaking maybe keynote
eventually we'll see CRO my youtube
channel you know just try to be a boss
[Music]
you know I'm so excited for you know
like life is hard life is hard but it's
also long and short so we just try to do
this yeah yes yes exactly
yeah awesome so Amy you also have a
YouTube channel like you mentioned yeah
it was about a lot of different stuff
can you tell us a little bit more about
YouTube channel one yeah so I started it
in March but I only recently became more
consistent the YouTube channel is Amy
Coates
yeah so what I like to talk about is
like technical and non-technical aspects
of being a software engineer I'm trying
to figure out like a good balance
between like vlogging and like technical
stuff and or like even daily look like
not daily vlogs but like a real life
walking around kind of vlog still try to
figure that out but I think like
whatever content I put out there y'all
it'll hopefully appreciate and that's a
lot of fun to make yeah and I think
y'all will really like it I think it's
very similar sort of to like my it was
well I wanted to mention that like I was
so happy so this morning we got friends
together and they're not the entire time
I was like oh my god this is the first
time I'm meeting another like techy
youtuber and it's like we can talk about
similar things and like relate to each
other
it's it this is a fun space I think I
would agree totally
yeah and I think it's something coming
too so it's really exciting tired yes it
is such an exciting us its revolution so
the last question I have for Amy is what
advice do you have for people who are
just getting into software engineering
and starting out that is a good question
so you think one piece of advice and
it's like not for everyone but if you
identify with this then it is so
incredibly beneficial and so what I
would say is is like create content
about the things that you're learning
about because it really gets yourself
out there it attracts an audience that
relate to similar things you may think
that the thing that you're you're trying
to write about is too basic or whatever
but that is so not true
people are stars are starting from
somewhere right and they will relate
the content that you create your
perspective is so important and having
different perspectives about even the
same topic maybe like people have
already talked about this but like
having different perspective and a
different way to teach it is so valuable
for me I have found creating content to
be incredibly valuable in terms of like
hunting down jobs because it's like you
may not perform super well that day at
your interview or whatever but people
will give you the benefit of the doubt
from all the content that you've created
and be like she knows what she's talking
about she's done conference Hawking
talks on this she's made YouTube videos
about this she's written blog posts
about this and I think that if you have
the time for it if you're the kind of
person that's interested in this stuff
create contest honestly yeah and you did
this while you're in school I did I did
do this I wrote like blog posts yeah
like I tried like talking like meetups
and things like that and also it's just
like builds the muscle memory of like
creating content in itself I think
initially people are too obsessed with
releasing perfect content which is
another piece of advice if you do want
to create content done is better than
perfect right just like keep on
releasing and keep on iterating and
eventually you'll get better at it and
like no one really cares if like the
thing that you create is not perfect on
the first shot like that's not an
expectation like the more you practice
and the more you release the better
you'll get that's so true yeah and you
don't have to wait until you graduate
college in order to do know ya start out
teaching other people really emphasizes
and like helps your memory and like help
ya to retain it better so teaching is
one of the best ways to learn things
yourself yes one of my friends who is a
consistent conference speaker she
actually like like learns things so that
she can talk about totally doing this
too you don't have to be an expert
already in order to talk at conferences
because when you are learning these
things it's when it's freshest in your
mind yes and you have the mindset of a
learner that you can teach other
last way honestly like i think within
our industry something that is very
undervalued is empathy and like you only
learn something once right and like
having that perspective fresh in your
mind and codifying it and like
formalizing that knowledge while you are
still learning this new thing is so
valuable because people forget like what
they trip up on when they first learn
something so that like empathy to like
understand where these people are coming
from that this topic even though other
people find it's like super easy is like
probably super hard for like people
first coming into whatever in each that
you're talking about and so I think
creating content also helps it like that
level of empathy and we'll eventually
like bring you on to huge and amazing
table yeah that's really good advice so
that's it for today Amy thank you so
much for being on my channel we had a
lot of fun we also did a collab on her
channel so don't forget to check that
out it'll be in the description box or
somewhere in this area
and as always like this video and
comment down below for what should we
ask them to comment about uh we should
ask them to comment what what who are
your favorite YouTube craft content
creators and what kind of content would
you like to see from tech youtubers oh
that's a good one yeah I've always been
curious about like what audiences are
interested in yeah so comment down below
for that and don't forget to subscribe
to my youtube channel for more videos
awesome
we'll see you next time bye hello hello
hello my you close by Tyra is going okay
okay
[Music]